vous voulez faire un petit tour du côté
des looks des stars on vous a sorti des
quatre coupes de stars qui font le plus
parler en ce moment d'abord il ya céline
dion céline dion qui a un nouveau look
complètement regarder d'un nouveau look
de selena alors d'aller en vous on a un
peu le même c'est vrai le même look and
feel est ce que vous aimez ça alors ça
c'est un look très sportswear
voilà c'est un look mi chic me
décontracte mi-campagne mi raisin sont
en panne sur l'autoroute la nuit autre
monde arabe arrêter là elle est en total
look dans une marque conçu par bike
finit par assia gars ouais c'est pas
bien parce que comme elle est très très
maigre loreo versailles
parce que c'est céline dion si moi je le
mette sortait les poubelles alors rien
un deuxième but qui a fait énormément
parler c'est une ex à emilie rattache
cops qui elle se débrouille pour
enflammer la toile celle ci de piqué et
plus avec moi elle veut me faire un
homme rôle cher grâce à une faute au
saut du lit à regarder m me lève mon
chapeau aux frais de goût regardez la
elle a posté une photo dimanche elle
avait recueilli 350 me like en une heure
voilà ce que vous avez déjà vu des gens
qui souhaitaient
patiemment est ce que vous l'avez
désabusé cette autoroute évoquera nom
qui se lèvent déjà lui il est même pas
contrôler mur le lit faut le pousser
contre murray avait serey die qui
travaille chez cascades
c'est vrai ça tu penses vraiment quand
tu vois si non il ya une troisième photo
qui a fait énormément parler c'est
kendall jenner
alors il est plus fort plus tôt forte
qu'on mélange et le business et le sexy
kendall regarder à l'occasion d'une
campagne publicitaire pour calvin klein
et là franchement
ben ouais la chaise c'est bien c'est
qu'à la différence de ses soeurs elle a
su garder son corps autant musique et il
est juste magnifique cheval songe pas de
tactique qu'à travers cette photo sur
les chaussettes la grosses chaussettes
exactement là grosses chaussettes c'est
très très excitant je vous le dis et si
je peux me permettre
pour vous un petit conseil de look ça la
grosse chaussettes serviable très fort
et la sauce est comme ça avec une tenue
un petit peu des habits des gains
marqués avec dans les films romantiques
souvent quand la fillette au saut du lit
qu'on la récupère au petit matin elle à
la chemise d'homme de sont de ceux-là et
les grosses chaussettes les miniatures
ouais mais bon déjà les banques elles
mêmes ainsi que moi j'y vais la droite
et gauche s'est elle achemine chaque
année vers je vais vous dire c'est
coluche un mois c'est le vendeur de
kebab
il ya une autre superstar qu'on avait
déjà vu kim kardashian regardez cette
photo analystes alors ça c'est mon
délire on va aller passer inaperçu mais
bon là c'est votre délire aux six mois à
l'arrivée j'adore j'en dirais mon
intérieur de voiture